if this is not a social Green Deal the
Green Deal will not happen if this is
not a Green Deal where the most
vulnerable regions in Europe coal mining
regions and others do not see solidarity
from other parts of Europe it will not
happen there's a lock open t think
Joaquin Madrid quiero dar la bienvenida
al plan Timmerman's unum Westra Clara
evidentally Durazo que eres de europa
cray Mo's llevar a cabo en la lucha
contra el cambio climatic o la social
democracy ax Valley dare our esta puesta
marcha de un cambio de Modelo ecological
social sustainable a que debemos decirle
passes de poner en marcha de manera or
frente por que no es una opción es una
obligación vamos a hacer no teniendo muy
claro que es necesario tener presupuesto
yo radio tambien approve atomos este
momento para rev in dakar a los estados
miembros que guarantee sane un
presupuesto suficiente una fiscally da
Costa para fair possible a este cambio
ecológico durante fond de la Justicia
Sophia this is a historical moment for
our family we were fighting for it in
the European elections as socialists and
now we shall be leading this transition
now I'd like to stress that for us the
most important thing is to protect our
planet the health of our people to
create new jobs which will be green and
also to protect people who may be harmed
during this transition because for us in
order to make this story a success we
need to make it just